Now, that we are armed with the knowledge of how d3 binds data and
how to work with enter selection, let us recreate the dimple JS chart in d3,
and then extend it to add further context.
Here we are back in the terminal.
And before we can see our chart, we have to run a HTTP server.
Again, I'm going to be using the python built in, simple HTTP server.
And we can see here, it's serving up our current folder.
Local host port 8000.
And as you can see here.
We have our world cup attendance scatter and line plot that we created in lesson
two where attendance is on the y-axis, and the year is on the x axis.
And each of these circles accurately represents the total attendance for
the World Cup held in that year.
Going back to our Sublime text window,
I want to step through the Dimple.js chart creation code here, and replace,
line by line, what Dimple.js does for us with native D3 itself.
One thing you'll notice is that even simple things, such as creating the chart
object or adding a y axis in D3, will end up being much more verbose.
Then there are in Dimple.js, but we'll have much more flexibility on what our
chart looks like and how to customize it.